All right, I hope everyone is doing well
and enjoying reading and meeting along
with fundamentals of active inference.
In the coming week, we are heading into
chapter four and beyond. And I've just
pushed an update to the open-source repo
Active Inference Institute Fundamentals.
And it takes us up through chapter 10.
So, this is the web interface.
Previously, we had chapters 1, 2, and 3.
This
update adds in chapter four on
variational Bayesian inference,
chapter five on predictive coding,
chapter six on generalized filtering for
perception,
chapter seven on active generalized
filtering
adding in action,
chapter eight learning, attention, and
hierarchical models,
chapter nine active inference in
partially observable Markov decision
processes,
and chapter 10 learning and extensions
of POMDPs.
So, you can interact with this directly
through the GitHub repo.
You can go to the output section,
look at the chapter-based outputs.
You can run it from the repo itself with
run.
And then you can regenerate all the
chapters with A.
You can
launch the web interface with W.
You can check out all the code in the
SRC.
You can look at the thin orchestrators
in the scripts.
You can check out the documentation
where each chapter has a document,
there's some reference documents, and
some details on statistics, other
topics.
So,
enjoy.
Leave a comment or make an issue on
GitHub if you want to make a suggestion
or ask question. Otherwise, Fraser,
Andrew, and I look forward to seeing you
in the coming textbook group meetings.
Thank you.